From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
Today is June 29, 2016. This is David Cline for the Civil Rights History Project of the Library of Congress and the National Museum of African American History and Culture.
I'm with the History Department at Virginia Tech. Behind the camera today we have John Bishop of Media Generation and UCLA.
I'm Guha Shankar from the Library of Congress. We're in Pasadena, California today and very, very pleased to have Maria Varela who came out here all the way from New Mexico to join us.
And this is the one time I'll coach you at all in our conversation. But if you could introduce yourself in a full sentence so we can use that later, my name is and where and when you are born.
Okay, my name is Maria Varela. I was born January 1st in the middle of a blizzard in 1940 in a little town in Pennsylvania called Newell, PA.
And can we start with your childhood or even before that with your family background, to get a sense of what shaped you as you then develop your life as an activist?
Well, certainly the family was not political and probably leaned a little to the conservative side, although we're socially open around issues of injustice.
I had a mother who was groupulously fair, which is why I think all of my four other sisters we all get along pretty well because there was never any favoritism.
So we learned about fairness, you know, sort of at the breast in a way.
And a dad, you know, who himself once they came to this country after during the revolution experienced, you know, his share of racism and ridicule.
In fact, they would joke about it because he came from six brothers and one sister and he and his two older brothers played football.
Well, he had been born in Mazapil, Zacatecas, Mexico. And they came over, I think, when he was nine.
And they thought they would stay around the San Antonio area for a while and then go back, but this revolution kind of dragged out further.
So they decided and there's such anti-immigrant sentiment. I mean, we think it's bad today. It was really bad then.
This was probably close to 1920. And if you remember in the early 20s, they were passing like the Chinese Exclusion Act. There was all of this stuff.
If an American from this United States citizen married somebody from Mexico, they would lose their citizenship. It was pretty stiff to say it kindly.
So I think then grandpa decided that they were going to go where there were not a lot of Mexicanos. And he had gone to school for mining up in Columbia University, which had a cooperative relationship to the Colorado School of Mines. So that's how he learned his mining.
So he decided to that they would go that direction. And that's where dad met my mother in high school. So he would always say that he and his brothers who made it on scholarship, football scholarship, made it because of the epitaphs that people would throw at them, like go home greaser and, you know, that just made them play all the harder and they won. They won a lot. So they all got scholarships, football scholarships.
He was an athlete. He played. I don't know. It wouldn't be kind of like farm team ball for a while and got invited to, you know, become whatever then was like full-time baseball player. Well, but turned it down.
So the poor man had five girls who were not particularly athletic, tried to try his best. He did, however, take me out of school to go hunting with him since I was oldest daughter. And there was no older son, oldest daughter had to stand in Lou.
And so we did several hunting trips from about the time I was 11 on and bought my own shotgun, which I ended up then taking south at a certain point when I joined the movement.
Can you do up with that?
I can't even come in handy.
Yeah.
So can you tell me a little bit about your early schooling and what that was like?
We went to Catholic schools. The Catholic high school that I went to was called terminal education.
Not that we were going to die when we graduated, but it was like we were trained. Actually, I got some very good training in shorthand and typing.
I had really good skills that way because most of the women, young women in that school, didn't come from families who either envisioned or could pay for them to go to college.
That was a different high school and dad couldn't really afford to put all of us into the more expensive high school that was more on a college track.
And so we were on the kind of secretary until you find a good husband track.
So I think dad didn't really envision us going to college.
He felt, you know, what women do is get married and have children and college is a waste.
He had been to college.
But for women, you know, that was not like the norm.
And what happened, I think, was, and this is by the time we had moved, we had moved several times.
By this time we were in Chicago.
And they have really good friends and the father in this family dropped dead one day.
He was like 45 years old, just dropped dead, leaving the widow with five children.
And, you know, looking at how is she going to support this family because she didn't have a whole lot of marketable skills.
And I think that changed my dad's mind.
Was that if something, I think it was some kind of a watershed in his thinking about what would happen to us.
So I was first born and we were trundled off.
I mean, he took me around to look at different colleges.
And fortunately for me, I settled on a Franciscan school called Alverno College in Milwaukee, which really was specifically designed for young women who either had one or two parents that had not had a college education.
They were definitely about, you know, taking blue collar kids, you know, from blue collar families, you know, and providing a college education.
So it wasn't like the other snooty schools that we went to.
I felt really uncomfortable in these other sort of more like finishing schools.
And this one was less so just because of the student body.
Can I ask you in terms of growing up in your family, did you, was it English only speaking out of the speaks banish?
No, because my grandfather was very strict about not wanting the boys to speak Spanish at all.
He'd get physical with them if they did.
And I think part of that was, I don't think he was happy with the accent that he had.
I'm discussing, you know, because, or I think he also didn't understand that you can perfectly manage two languages and be excellent in both.
But I think he wanted them to be excellent in English.
So he was very strong about that.
And on your mother's side, was her heritage?
She was Irish, basically Irish and German.
Her father raised money for the IRA, which is probably worth it.
Some of the DNA that came through, you know.
Thank you very much.
Yes.
Okay, so the Francis can college that?
Yeah.
It was a good, yeah.
And I think what was very formative, and it's difficult to explain this, but there was an era in the Catholic church when
there was the sense that social engagement was the core of the religion and not the sort of collateral.
Well, if you want to, you know, throw some money at the poor, do that.
And this was, so there was a movement called the social inquiry movement.
And it was within families, called the Christian Family Movement.
It was in working people.
It came out of the Belgian worker priest movement.
This whole thing is Second World War, which was basically sort of upending the kind of church pyramid
where saying that lay people, you know, were charged, and if the clergy didn't want to go along well, too bad.
Because we need to be out there.
Because conditions for workers were horrible, as you know, at the turn of the century.
And of course there was an encyclical that kind of gave the charge, which is Pope Leo XIII, which said society has to be restructured for justice.
The man didn't know what he was talking.
When he was kind of engaged in.
And a lot of that, the whole resistance movement that involved in France and Belgium and Germany, that involved Catholics,
work inside by side with Jewish people and with atheists and with everything.
Really upended things in the church.
And so one of the products, though all of that, was this sort of, you know what?
You can't just tell people that they have to be engaged.
You have to train people.
It was a fantastic training where the social inquiry was, you tried to figure out what the problem was.
And you did that by going out and asking the people affected by the problem.
It wasn't go research it out of some book and have some academic tell you what the problem is.
You go find it out, you know.
Yeah, at that time, because we're looking at the 50s, 40s and 50s doing this.
And then you were supposed to come back and say, okay, so let's think, let's reflect.
What should this, how could this be remedied?
What should this community look like so that this wouldn't happen anymore?
And then we'd say, well, yeah, but do we know enough?
And so then you'd get, go back out.
It was like peeling an onion. After about four or five, we'd have weekly meetings.
You kind of begin to get to the core and it was like, oh wow, what a, especially if you're in a Catholic college, because you're supposed to look at your milieu.
And what are barriers there to people loving each other or to people not feeling ostracized or bullied or to, you know, the nuns getting it wrong, you know, which those were always fun things to do.
They didn't like that.
But.
Any inputs from community or I'm thinking of solos, entities who worked with the Catholic Church.
This is before, even before.
This solos was working in the 50s, right?
Yeah.
He didn't design this.
This came out of France and Belgium.
In fact, he could have been influenced by it.
Yeah.
Okay. So we're talking about the young Christian students.
Yeah. So I was involved in that in high school because your choice, you were expected to belong to some group.
So there's Sodality which preyed the rosary a lot, which I just loved.
There was the young Christian students, which was just seemed like more fun.
And in the process of being more fun, you know, you learned this.
And you never could leave a meeting without some kind of action, even if it was go get some more information.
So it kind of was the opposite of what's often in young people's movements.
That especially start in educational circles where there's a lot of theory and a lot of, you know, analyzing.
But not a whole lot of action.
Well, this didn't let you do that.
Which why it was a brilliant method.
I'm trying to get to the bottom of it.
I've been doing so much research.
And since I'm limited and not being able to read French, you know, which is where you see some of the roots in this.
I'm just intrigued about how this came, how this came about.
In any case, when I went to college, I discovered being a homesick, you know, freshman, that they had a young Christian students there.
So I thought, oh, I'm going to join.
I know all about this.
So I joined and was in it for four years.
And the nice thing about the young Christian students was that their whole thrust was, you got to get out of the Catholic ghetto.
You got to just not have this be a part of the national Catholic students organization.
You have to really get involved with the National Student Association, NSA, because that's, you know, students from across the country.
That's where we belong.
You know, and of course, the nuns thought that maybe the NSA was little communist because you don't forget this.
It's like the McCarthy era, a little after the McCarthy era.
What are the years?
So the years I'm in college were 50s.
So I think I graduated high school in 57.
57 to 61, is that about right?
Yeah.
So the McCarthy era was like in those mid-50s.
I remember watching the hearings on television.
But in any case, because of the involvement with YCS, I was able to kind of get a window on other students who were not Catholic, and what their interests were.
And I became student body president and decided that I petitioned that I could go to the National Student Association Congress.
I actually also went in my junior year.
And the way I did it was I used my high school typing and stentil training to work in the Secretariat, which meant that my room and board was paid because the nuns weren't going to pay for it.
But I could go, you know.
So in that process is where I heard SNCC folks, student on violent coordinating committee sit in participants and leaders who came because they wanted the NSA to go on record.
And I was able to go on record to support the sit-ins.
And it was a huge struggle because of the block of Southern schools in the NSA that wanted nothing to do with that.
And I was blown away how articulate these folks that were like my age and how they could just every argument that came up.
And they were very nice about it.
I mean they were really not hostile.
I don't know the word to use, but could were able to defeat the arguments, but in a way that wasn't, you know, battering your enemy down into the trenches.
And so that was my first window to that.
And then...
Do you remember any particular personalities?
The Charles McDew was there. Tim Jenkins was there a lot.
He had some relationship to NSA.
He was very articulate as was Chuck.
And John Lewis may have come.
I'm really not sure about that.
So I had been to two before I graduated.
Also met...
I don't know if I met Tom Hayden by then.
I did.
I met Tom Hayden at the National School because he was trying to do this liberal caucus that evolved into eventually SDS.
Because I remember...
I don't know how...
You know the interesting thing about this age is that it's really...
It's community organizing. It's really all relationships.
And it's sometimes even mysterious how they happen.
Because here I'm I from this little Podunk school in Milwaukee, Wisconsin, you know, with absolutely no background.
Never read C. Wright Mills, never read Marx, didn't have a clue what they were talking about.
You know, but somehow through relationships I ended up attending their caucus.
Did you meet Connie Curry at that time too?
Later.
I don't remember specifically, but I could have.
I had a lot of work in the secretary. Maybe this is what it was. I've worked in the secretary at which meant if that liberal caucus wanted to bring some kind of resolution through that they wanted the body to pass, well come through me or others, there were three of us that were through a four of us.
You knew everything I was going on?
Well, they come and ask me, yeah.
So I got my feet wet in a world that I really didn't understand very much.
But I liked the people very much. I liked their values. I liked the way they would stand up for things.
So that's kind of how it gets started, you know.
So then when did you have a more formal relationship with you?
What I remember is that Tom got a hold of me and said, oh, then what happened?
In my senior year, I got an offer from the young Christian students, national staff. Would I join them and help organize, be a staff member?
Because we had various functions that we did among them doing organizing on both Catholic campuses and public school campuses that had Newman centers.
Because some of them had the young Christian students in there. And I'm going to move my blouses. It okay.
And so I did, one of my advisors had gotten me a fellowship at Marquette University in speech therapy.
'Cause she suggested to me that that's what I should do. I had no clue what that was about and I had that well.
I guess I got to do something with my college education. Speech was my major. Although I did act. I was also an actor.
But so I kind of just said, okay. So she had me apply for it. And I got accepted. And then this offer came from the young Christian students.
She said to me, you can postpone it for a year. So that's what happened. I accepted the offer for the young Christian students.
Went to Chicago where their headquarters were. Lived in rat-infested apartments on the west side. Because there was no money.
We got $7 a week room and board. I mean, we truly lived like Catholic worker, you know, kind of communities.
But we're much more activist in some ways. I shouldn't say that because I don't really know a lot.
Catholic worker communities are different from place to place. So as I was on the national staff for the young Christian students,
Tom Hayden got a hold of me and said, we're going to do this Port Huron Conference conference to put together a manifesto.
Didn't know what that meant. And we're trying to be, he didn't use the word, but he meant ecumenical about it.
Because they were trying to get out of their ghetto. They're sort of leftist ghetto. And the other interesting thing about this era is that student organizations were almost always attached to adult organizations.
Students weren't thought of as competent enough or that age group to do their own thing, which is why SNCC was such an incredible accomplishment because the NAACP and the SCLC wanted to appendage them.
And the students said, no. And it's like Diane Nash said, we brought the town of Nashville to their knees. Why do we need adult overseers?
And I think the SDS then sort of took note because they were involved in the different alphabets on the left. They were red diaper babies, essentially, which meant that they were just raised up in this kind of left enclave, often from Eastern European.
Sort of families. And.
But there was some, some of them had a faith-based activist background as well.
That's what I found out when we went to Port Huron Conference. Yeah, no, exactly right. I only remember that because Tom asked me to meet him in New York. I was back east.
And he said, me and Al Haber want to talk to you. Can you come and we met at some place in New York. I think it was the oyster bar or something.
And he said, this is what we want to do. And we'd like to invite YCS to be a part of this. And I thought, wow, that's pretty amazing.
Well, earlier that day, he and Al had taken me to their little office. They were part of an organization under SLID, SLID.
And there was, I was in this building. I think it was a lower east side. And you had these little cubby holes with glass doors. And there were all these names of like old left.
Somebody Albanians for whatever, you know, kind of. And it's like, I thought, God, this is a whole different world, you know. And nothing about this world.
But anyway, so I said, I'll take it back to the team and see what they say. And then, so I did go to Port Huron Conference. And there I met Casey Hayden.
And I met other SNCC folks, including Tim Jenkins. Got to spend more time then with them than at an NSA meeting.
Spent a week in Port Huron Conference, just about. And so that was it. I helped Casey. I actually have the original minutes of the student of the Port Huron Conference conference that I typed on.
I just found those.
And then about three months later, I get this letter from Casey saying, we really need help here in the office. I guess things were just blowing up. This is 1960.
The end of 62, you know, they had basically all this campus presence. There were all these sit-ins happening. There were all these affiliations that groups were.
So I think in that era, they were making the decision to field full-time field workers. People would leave school. As Julian said, just for five years, we're going to do this. We'll get this job done in five years.
And that created a lot of work in the office. And Casey remembered my great St. Louis Academy skills and said, what I come down and work.
So you've been involved in the Port Huron Conference statement. Yeah.
The recollection is not real clear. I did write a whole essay on, you know, some of the things that went on. There was.
You know, there was just some semantical issues that Tom says I solved for them. And I don't know if I did or not.
I always felt that there's the language of that authenticity. And that is very much a student question with that.
Yeah. Well, Casey came out of the young Christian women's organization. This is back to your point. There were faith-based people who got involved because it wasn't just the Catholic, that sector of the Catholic church that wanted engagement.
You know, you found that in Presbyterians or Piscopalians. Certainly, you know, the Jewish faith, that was very much a part of it, you know, the engagement.
And that was a strong presence there at Port Huron Conference. But, yeah.
So that was part of the language, yeah. So I didn't want to go and just procrastinated and I'm not going to tell them they're kill people.
Well, she wanted me to go to the Atlanta office, you know. And I finally, finally just decided, well, you're pretty hypocritical if you're up here in these campuses, exhorting these Catholic students to get engaged and support the civil rights movement.
And they asked you to go down and you're going to tell them no. But it did take me probably three, four months to make up my mind.
So I did. And in the process, because NSA and Connie Curry and SNCC were running a summer school for these young kids that would just do these actions in these southern towns where there wasn't a huge movement presence.
And they were just getting thrown in jail. They were just getting beaten. So it was, I think Connie's idea. Let's bring them in for training.
Let's treat them not to train them in nonviolent strategies. Black history, other kinds of topics. It was, I think, a six week school.
And I've been trying to track down the curriculum there, you know, because I remember it. Robert Coles was there, Robert Coles.
He was a real important role. He was truly an astounding man is, I guess. But that's where I first learned about Afro-American history. It blew me. It just exploded in my head.
You see in this era, do you remember for the eulogy for Muhammad Ali, where was a Billy Crystal that said when lightning would strike, that Muhammad was like, when lightning strikes, how it illuminates everything around you. And it's this big charge.
That's the way our sort of epiphanies were. And our, as we, it's hard to explain because I realized that I was only there almost five years. But it was like I was there for a lifetime.
Because of all that I learned. And the learning curve was way shortened, you know, just because it was such an intense moment when lightning was striking all the time and illuminating things that people had told you it was this way and you find out, oh no, it was this way.
And it's like, what the heck? You know, why I had these elders lied to us all these years, you know, which really fed into this movement's strength to stand when everybody else said we were wrong because we could really, you know, so my, one of my first epiphanies after going south was black history, you know, and how none of that was in my curriculum or education. And it's like,
but I watched the impact on these young black kids, especially young black men. They were holding themselves differently. It was like, wow, you know, we're not trash. Look at our, look at the achievements, look at our ancestors.
They made a huge difference in the way that they began paying attention to everything else that was coming their way in this summer school.
And I just, it was a big lesson burned into my brain.
So I was sitting in the cafeteria one day. And Frank Smith, who was a snake full time staff worker. I can't remember where Frank was from.
Because I watched Frank drive in to the campus and he had this old beat up Ford station wagon. And it was like a bunch of straw. And I thought, kind of the guy drool through, he feels to get here anymore this battered old cowboy hat.
And we sat down and had lunch together. So he asked me about me. And where I came from and I told him, you know, I came out of a tone about young Christian students and had this funny look on his face. I thought, ooh, what's that about?
So it was either that day or the next day Bernard Lafayette Jr had come in who also had worked. Selma, but broke his leg and had to get out of there because they beat him terribly.
So Bernard and Frank had lunch with me and said, what would you think about going to Selma? I was like going, are these guys nuts? You know, it's like, I just kind of looked, you know, in my sort of deer in the headlight expression.
And they said, and this is why. And they explained it. There is this, these French Canadian father, Marie Soulette, who lay is the way you would say it. And he's the pastor of St. Elizabeth Mission, which was an Afro-American Catholic church, of which there were very few across the South.
But Selma had a long tradition that Edmundites, which is an order, had had a hospital there. See, they were kind of, it was interesting because they created jobs for black people in the hospitals, in their whole fundraising apparatus, just employed nothing but people from the black community.
So it was both, you know, creating sort of industry and he had a school, they had a Catholic school.
Anyway, he was a very strong supporter of the movement. And could be because he didn't work for any white people. He did have a bishop that was not a supporter of the movement at all, but he was in Montgomery.
And father really wanted to have some literacy training. He felt, because then people could take that 21 question voter registration test. It's a ridiculous test.
And quite honestly, there really wasn't any hope for even if you could read. They would, they had the option to ask you these crazy questions at the end, and they could say, no, you're wrong, sorry. And then you just failed the test.
But in any case, I think our thinking was, we could do a class action lawsuit of some sort, if there were just enough people who were readers. So he asked me what I do. I knew nothing about adult literacy, how do adults learn to read, you know, whatever.
And, but that's what they wanted me to do. They said, here's the deal.
We need you to go to Selma to support this man because he's very important to the Selma movement. And because you're Catholic and you can, you know, support him, that'll keep him strong.
And then do whatever you want you to do, you know, so. And also, I think worth long was on this next half and worth one of the literacy.
There was a lot of this thinking through SNCC at this point in 63 about literacy training and we had to learn a whole lot about that.
So yeah, I said, I guess I'll go, especially what happened was they said, well, just take a trip out there and meet him.
And I really liked him immediately. He was just such a neat person. And, you know, had come out of his own, you know, French Canadians weren't always well regarded.
And he had that kind of family DNA, I suppose you say. So he really, he was very strong, but not in like a really paternalistic way at all.
It was just, you know, one of that way. So I ended up in Selma.
Can I ask you about your own self identity at that time in terms of your heritage and your background and sort of what you were thinking about your own background.
I was imagining you, you know, being immersed in African American history and wondering if that sort of put off some sparks of inquiry for yourself.
Yeah, it's hard to say because we didn't grow up, we moved so much, we didn't grow up in a Mexican community.
Of course, there wasn't Spanish spoken in our house. My dad was very proud of his heritage and has oldest daughter, you know, that was something a heritage that I myself sort of internalized and felt strongly about.
But didn't have any, I had mentioned it a couple times when I was growing up in school and got really slapped down by one non-imparticular who said, we're all American here because I said to my seatmate, my next again, she heard me, she comes walking down the aisle, she scared the crap out of me.
That's something I didn't forget for a long time, a little PTSD there and she just was like, no, we are all American here.
You know, I'm like, oh God, what's wrong with being Mexican? I guess there's something wrong with being Mexican.
So I'm starting to internalize this and like, well, I don't really care what you think, but this is what I am, but I'm not going to say anything.
I've never said anything. You just learned that lesson, you know.
So yes, learning black history then, you're beginning to think, oh, what else don't I know? You know, I wasn't there yet, but that certainly did end up sparking that a couple years later.
All right, so Selma.
Well, Selma was.
The pressure in Selma was, I really realized I knew nothing about how adults learn.
What father said was, here's a lady Mrs. Kathy, she really wants to learn to read.
Let me tell her that you'll come and teach her a couple times a week.
And she wants to learn to read the Bible.
The difficulty was, as we would start, she already knew that, but I couldn't tell if it's because she had memorized the Bible or she actually could read it.
And I was beginning to watch, of course, we learned this in YCS, you watch, you know, observe, judge, enact, observe, reflect the act.
Some watching, and I'm thinking, you know, she knows some of these words and big words.
And she knows what they mean, but she doesn't think she can read.
And she doesn't think she can write either, but she can't do some.
So I began to kind of just through my own observations, realized that, and she's just one person, so what did I know?
But maybe adults who were nonreaders already had some basic reading skills, but not basic in the sequential start with the little words and then go to the big words and the bigger words after that.
They actually had a variety of vocabulary, and it depended on what they wanted to know, or what they got exposed to, you know, that helped them pick up and remember what that word was in context.
And so it was really perplexing. I'm going through a lot of my papers now, and I'm like, I'm trying to figure this out.
I did learn from some of my SDS buddies that foundations were very interested in having their literacy programming developed within the civil rights movement towards voter education, voter registration.
So, Rennie Davis, who was an SDS leader, wrote me my first proposal, you know, which got funded.
Then I had to do something with money. But part of it was to learn, you know, and I'm piecing this together now.
I will tell you that there's a lot of, it's like Swiss cheese in my mind right now. How did I get from here to there?
'Cause I've got my proposals, and they do exhibit a kind of an intuitive but almost experiential understanding of what you have to do with adult literacy, but I don't know how I got there.
So, I'm trying, again, it's like one of those things where you have encounters and people who really influence you, you just then forget how that came about.
The long, make a long story short, I decided, okay, I'm going to recruit four to six Afro-American students to come work in SELMA for the summer of 64.
And two, so that we can try out the development of literacy materials that can be used across the SNCC programs, across Mississippi, Louisiana, you know, wherever SNCC was working.
And I got the money for it, and then Ruby Doris Smith Robinson in the Atlanta SNCC office said to me, oh, you know Bob Moses is planning this summer program in Mississippi.
I said, really? She said, yeah, let's see, what's wrong with this picture? She didn't say this, but this is what she meant.
You're bringing in four to six Black kids to SELMA, and he's bringing a thousand White kids to Mississippi. There was some, we had some real issues about that program.
So, in any case, oh yeah, I thought it was a horrible idea. I knew what I had to go through to just get four students trained so they wouldn't get themselves killed, and these are Black students, you know.
And to figure out how they could be effective, because, you know, students are very oriented towards class deadlines and, you know, homework deadlines.
And their time is constrained, and then you bring them into SELMA and say, okay, let's work.
And they had a, I did not realize. I should have had a more structured situation, but some rose above, you know, like cream, and they started to do some really good stuff.
We were trying to figure out how to reach that non-reader to bring them into classes so we could try some of these ideas that we had.
One idea being like the experience story, which is, you know, tell us an experience, we'll put it up in the board, and then you speak to this, anyway.
Well, then, Lyndon (Johnson) signed the Civil Rights Act July 2, 1964. On July 3rd or 4th, do you remember? I can't remember.
July 3rd probably, because the next day my students go down to the Thirsty Boy it's called to get served.
They're figuring out, well, it's the law of the land, isn't it? It's like, but this is SELMA.
So, you know, five minutes later, here's Jim Clark with his cattle prod, and they were trundle off the jail.
That one, there, one our summer. So I spent the next four weeks raising bail and getting them out and dodging Clark, because there was a warrant out from my arrest.
And then we were, we were in, and the reason for the warrant was because SELMA City Council had passed a regulation that there could be no meetings of two or more people without a permit, and especially for Bidden, and then they listed SNCC and WACP, you know, they listed the groups that just weren't going to get a permit anyway.
So because we had, anyway.
And did the church, the church didn't give any, there was any protection of the church, or...
No, he thought it was like, why did they do that? This is SELMA.
You know, but these kids, except for Silas Norman, who was from Augusta, Georgia, they were from the North, you know.
And...
Were you aware of what was going on in Mississippi?
Not a lot. No, because we were so focused on getting this program done in SELMA.
When I think about it, SELMA was probably the stupidest place to do a program where you're trying to learn how to...
There was just too much, I mean, it was like a Nazi state, you know. It was...
Mississippi was bad too, but you had little places in Mississippi where you could take refuge and not be ratted out, or, you know,
stuff like that. SELMA was really horrible.
So in the process of learning what I was doing in SELMA, I did have some SNCC organizers in Mississippi when I went to staff meeting in the fall, say, well, you know, we're trying to do this.
And we need some booklets.
By that time I had evolved to the idea...
Okay, look, literacy should be much more around what do people want to learn about rather than here's CAT, C-A-T, you know what I mean?
What do they want to learn about? Because they will learn to read, or they will upgrade their reading skills if they get something they want to read for whatever reason.
So I don't know how this idea came, but there was this group of Afro-American farmers in Batesville, Panola County, Mississippi, Mississippi.
And they did an Okra Co-op. They had an equipment co-op before that.
Then they decided to do an Okra Co-op. And the idea evolved. And I know there's probably a lot of people who played a role in this. It isn't just my idea.
And it was, let's do a booklet or two, and a film strip. So other farmers in other places can learn.
Because there were no materials that showed black people in leadership positions accomplishing things to better the community.
And that was the sense. This is where the convergence of adult readers being able to upgrade their skills, but also people learning how to do something could come together in these books.
And so we did these kinds of books. And they had photographs of black people doing things and making change.
And I had no idea about the response. And I only found this out about two months ago. I'm going through my files.
And it's like, we need 1,000 of these books over here. People just asking for them all over.
And one woman wrote and said, I can't tell you how proud I am to know that my own people have done something like that that makes such a change.
So it created a lot of pride. Plus one organized, SNCC organizer said to me, if you bring these books over here, do not please pass them out in the beginning of the meeting.
Because I can never get people to pay attention to the meeting. Because they're all into the books. There were two of them going through the different phases that the co-op did to organize.
So this is the whole practical way of taking what is needed in terms of social justice and having people give themselves, give their own folks the information on how to make changes.
It was a big, huge thing that just woke, I mean, the whole striving for education in Mississippi, Alabama, the least places where I worked was incredible.
People who you could not get to come out for voter registration. If you had a Freedom School, which later turned into Head Start in 65, 66, if you want a pair to come out for those meetings, they were there.
They were there just because their children's education was almost more important to them than going down and voting.
So we could reach a whole different group of people through these kinds of materials, which we did a whole bunch of different kinds. Well, maybe not a whole bunch, but it was very diverse what we did.
So that was a lot of my work. There's a lot of sort of in the mainstream narrative about the movement that, well, you know, you've heard this, the student sat down, Martin, no, how did it go?
Rosa sat down, Martin stood up and Lyndon signed the Civil Rights Act. And so after the Selma March and the signing of the Voter Rights Act, and nobody ever thought to ask, well, how are you going to get people down to the polls?
And who's going to do that? Well, we had boots on the ground, nobody else did. So SNCC had a lot of work to do still in 65, 66, and 67.
And the sort of mainstream narrative was, they're not doing anything, you know, nothing's happening. There was so much going on, especially in Mississippi, but also in Alabama, and Georgia around economic things that people wanted to do.
Of course, voter registration, educational things that people wanted to do, health things. So in a sense, that lightning struck with the students coming in and breaking apart things.
And it's like a second reconstruction. It's like all of that energy that came after the Civil War when the federal troops were able to protect people. And all that they did the 2000 schools they built across, it was very similar, very similar in the South in the mid 60s, almost to the 70s.
So were you still based in Selma during this time where you moved?
I moved. Yeah, I moved to a went to Mississippi, and I found a little house. There's, there's Tougaloo College. And then across the state road, there was Tougaloo College, where people who worked at the college lived, little, little shotgun shack.
So I, I had inherited a house that I took over from some other people who had come down the summer of 64. And so I took over the rent of that house. And then Bobby Fletcher and I built a dark room because in order to do these books, if we wanted to show black people doing things, well, we had take those pictures because they weren't, there weren't any kind of general photography files anywhere.
Anywhere that would show that. And so I kept begging Bobby, would they come with me to Batesville and take these pictures for my books? Finally, he said, how did you just do it yourself? I said, I don't know how to work a camera.
So that's when he told me that there was a man, a Matt Herron, who was a commercial photographer. And he lived in New Orleans, and he was a brilliant ally of SNCC, it's several were.
And that he said he would take any SNCC person and have them come stay with him in Janine for a week. And he would teach them to shoot and develop film and print.
And so I thought, well, I guess I'm going to have to do that because if I can't get Fletcher to help me with these books that are not going to happen.
So I had some grant money as a part, that's all these, you know, that continued. The foundations that supported me, there were two or three and they kind of continued their support of the work because they saw stuff coming out of it.
So I went and spent this would have been the spring of late winter of 65. I spent in New Orleans spent a week and learned to shoot to print, which was Matt's approach.
Matt was taught by a person who was a student of Ansel Adams, so there was this whole, so it's like this black and white documentary photography, we learned the gray scale.
You know, it really wasn't just pick up your thing and it was like, here's how you compose, it was like, move, move yourself to get a good frame shot. You know, you don't just stand there.
And it was, I was truly blessed to have that kind of, even though again, it was just a week, but it's like everything else that happened to us.
It was so intense, it was such an intense week. And of course, I did some pretty crappy work after that because we only taught, we only learned available light photography.
So we had no automatic anything, so I had to learn the hard way, some really thin negatives and some very thick negatives, that's what I ended up in the beginning.
And that's when I started, you know, the photography part of it. And part of our responsibility as SNCC photographers was to cover any events because the sense was cameras were an extra eye on a situation that might protect the marchers.
So I did cover the James Meredith March Against Fear, I have a number of negatives on James Meredith March Against Fear. And I actually found that I enjoyed, I really liked photography.
But it wasn't the only thing I did, I didn't identify myself as a photographer. I am today in some circles identified as a photographer for SNCC, but I wasn't at the time because I was doing it in service of these other,
whatever organizers, SNCC organizers needed in the communities, they would ask for help and we would produce something. So that's how the photography thing came about.
But you were often there with a camera, and you didn't have a lot of, were there other female photographers?
You know, I don't think so. Well, actually there may have been, but because I found out later, but as far as on SNCC staff know, but there were people who came down. I think there's a woman named Kathy Cade who did some work.
There's another woman, and I think she just died, who did also some work, but, and they may have been attached to magazines, or I'm actually not quite sure. But as far as being full time in the field, there were nine of us who were SNCC photographers.
We had the only photography department of all the civil rights organizations. Martin King and the SCLC kind of cultivated, you know, photographers who would capture the stuff they wanted. We didn't do that, you know, because our purpose as SNCC photographers was to show not the celebrities in the movement, but to show the local folks who were the leaders, without which the movement could not move.
And so a lot of us have some really good stuff. We, and some of it's been captured in this exhibit that just finished in Allentown, PA at the museum called This Light of Ours: Activist Photographers of the Civil Rights Movement, and it has a great catalog with a lot of our work.
This might be a strange question, but did the camera help you to see things differently in any way?
No, I think the camera was expressing the way I was seeing, because I already was living in the black community. It's not like I came from New York and discovered a beautiful black child's face. I mean, I was already surrounded by that, you know, and the camera like helped me frame it and capture it.
So what were some of the other places that you went with camera or with the other projects that you worked on?
Oh, later as I moved to New Mexico, I ended up, I did about 14 roles on the Poor People's Campaign, showing mostly the Latino participants.
I think there's been a lot of work on the African-American participation in that. And so I did a lot of that, and I have some really interesting.
Most of my stuff that came as a part of the Chicano movement, as I sort of migrated into that, has not really ever been seen, because except for that, which I was able, which we had 33 Latino newspapers across.
Now we're talking in 1968, 69.
Can you take us out of SNCC then, your journey?
Well, you know, there was a lot of work that I was engaged in. I was working with Mrs. Fannie Lou Hamer. I actually did her first autobiography.
She taped her, me and Julius Lester, and transcribed it and created this book.
Can you tell us just a little bit about Mrs. Fannie Lou Hamer?
Oh, she was...
She was...
I don't know. It was like... I remember...
I was helping a little bit her campaign when she was running for office after the whole sort of debacle at Atlantic City.
And the FDP started running its own candidates.
So I'd be at her house, often, and plus we were doing this.
But just a sort of...
I showed up with one of my sisters, and I remember who it was one afternoon, because I told her I was coming.
And so she met me at the door and she said,
All right, and if you pregnant? And I said, I looked at my sister.
Are you pregnant?
She said, no. Are you sure?
She said, yeah. She said, because we're cutting up hog here, and it will spoil the hog if either of you are pregnant.
You know, and who knows? There might have been something to that, honestly.
Hormones.
So...
Well, then, of course, if she's in the middle of something like that, you just don't go in there and, you know, so there we are cutting hog,
which leaves your hands so beautiful.
And taking the fat out to Fannie Lou Hamer, I have this great picture of Fannie Lou Hamer in the back with a big black kettle, and boiling oil.
And he's making what we call chicharrones.
So this started this conversation between me and Mrs. Fannie Lou Hamer.
I said, you know, that my dad loves those. I said they're called chicharrones.
And then we started talking about sort of similarities between Mexican at least flavors.
You know, black-eyed peas, pinto beans, and corn tortillas, and corn bread.
Not exactly the same, but, you know, and then Mrs. Fannie Lou Hamer always used like these red chili flakes in her collards.
And that's practice too, in that.
So we'd have these great conversations, and she was just like really easy to talk to.
And very, very committed person.
And a lot of people don't know this about Mrs. Fannie Lou Hamer.
When those food trucks, donation trucks, would come down from the north.
And she was on that, she was on that sort of railroad of that.
There were, I think about four or five white families that she knew were just dirt poor.
And she would always get them supplied with any of the stuff that came down.
She was, she was a person.
She didn't understand why we didn't want to have this project in 64.
With all these white students come down.
She didn't understand why some folk had some some some snow folks had issues with that.
And I think finally, because she spoke up after, oh, just hours of debate.
She said, look, I don't want to be a part of an organization that doesn't want to reflect the kind of society that we want.
And it's like Charles E. Cobb Jr said, who's a snick worker.
He said, you know, because he really disagreed with it too.
That's that I, you know, a lot of people, he said, you know, we're here to serve the people here.
That's what Mrs. Fannie Lou Hamer and the other local folks want.
We'll do it.
So it was, yeah, she was something else.
Working with Mrs. Fannie Lou Hamer?
Yeah, I worked with her for a while, but it was, I was really distributing the books, you know, I had film strips.
I did a film strip because the people in the, well, this is a whole technology that we learned.
There were some supporters in New York who told us about that they could build us a film strip printer, which was this sort of long thing about this high.
And what you did was, how did that go?
You, we, we storyboarded, you know, the, and shot the frames.
And then we, we bought positive film and laid that down and put the negative film on top of it and exposed it for so long and then developed it.
And that was a film strip.
They were really cheap. You can make a pretend sense of peace.
You could do like 25 a day, you know.
And because the feeling was, we knew people responded so much better to visuals.
We also knew that our organizers couldn't be everywhere.
So we did a script for it that just went frame by frame so that if those of us who had worked on the film strip weren't there, it didn't matter.
Because, and then we had these little envelopes that the script would fit into, fold it in half.
And at the end of it was a little canvas bag.
And that's where you stuck the tin with the film strip in it.
You can send it off to anybody, anywhere.
In fact, I know I made film strips for this and they're not one left.
They just got nationally distributed through the co-op, what's it called?
The co-op organization in Washington, DC. I can't remember the name.
Because there were so few materials showing people doing co-ops and basically, anyway, it's.
So, I did one at the request of the people trying to organize a Mississippi Freedom Labor Union.
And they said, would you go and document, says our Chavises United Farm Workers and how they did things.
So we could show the people up here in the Delta that there are the people, you know, who have done this, who have faced a lot of terrible violence in trying to do.
So I did, I con-t, we had had a couple of volunteers that worked for SNCC.
A lot of people don't know this too, was that they came to, this was Marshall Ganz and George Ballis, I believe, who were volunteers for SNCC in that summer of 64.
And who came to the SNCC staff meeting that September and came up to me and said, listen.
We want to ask if SNCC would be willing to support the Farm Workers Union with a couple of surplus cars and CB radios because the union, like, really needs them.
And we did, we had a fleet and Ruby Doris took them from people who were messing them up so she had them in the yard.
So, and he said, so we want to put this proposal before the body and would you support us?
I said, yeah. So, I supported and SNCC did. They sent over at least two, maybe three, Plymouth Valiants, and about two, three, maybe five CB radios.
I'm not sure what else they sent over. So we were the first, SNCC was the first Afro-American civil rights organization really because, since I had tried to get Martin involved and that didn't go well.
And so I knew about those two guys. So I called them up and I said, look, this is what people in Mississippi would like.
So can I come over and shoot some frames and George, who was a fantastic photographer who died, I think this year.
He said, yeah, come on, let's do this. So we shot together and he already had some files.
And so we put together a script and collaboration with the people at the farm workers to make sure it wasn't going to screw it up.
And then George helped me with some photographs and I did some of mine.
George Ballis. Yeah, he was a great photographer. He did the farm workers mainly, but he did for a while work on SNCC stuff.
I think maybe just a summer or a year.
So father, McKnight from Louisiana, Northern Louisiana, he was an Afro-American Catholic priest really believed in co-ops
and really believed that the movement had to get involved in economic organizing.
And so he pulled together a meeting of people who had been plantation workers who had been thrown off their plantation because they tried to vote.
And we're living in tent cities. And just a variety of people, he just invited people down.
And he asked me to come and to show the film strip of Panola County (Batesville MS) Okra Co-op.
And I said to him, when I got there, I said, so I had this film strip about, you know, the farm workers, could I show that too?
He said, oh, yes, sure.
So I guess it was the second or third day. And I just showed it, it was up on the walls of the turtall.
And it showed, you know, the farm workers and the sheriff's, you know, carting them off the jail because they were picketing.
And it showed all the hard work. It took them and what they were doing, the opposition and everything.
And after it was over, I was like, this dead silence. And I thought, well, this one didn't work very well.
And he was like, there's like nothing, you know. And then this older gentleman got up and he said, you don't know what it feels like to know that we're not the only ones I could never say that without crying.
He just like, it blew him away. He would have tears in his eyes, you know. It just, it was like, wow, it's just not us black people.
You know, there's other people that the sheriff's are trying to beat up to. So that had an interesting impact on people.
The mistake we made.
Did I have an impact for you?
Well, it was very reaffirming of our decision. However, there was a mortal flaw in our decision to do film strips. And that is we assumed in every school there would be a film strip projector.
And if there were, that didn't mean that any organizer could just automatically get one because the schools weren't always supportive of the movements.
Some individuals were, but the schools felt jeopardized by supporting or in the really poor black schools, there weren't any film strip projectors.
So we made a technological decision thinking how smart we were to use accessible technology that was cheap, never thinking it through totally.
But they're there for the record, I guess.
So how long did you continue to work with Ritz Neck and how did that?
I feel it worked when this whole supposed decision that was taken in SNCC, which is really not a decision at all, that people who weren't black would be thrown out.
That's not my experience.
However, I think that John Lewis was very hurt when he was not re-elected chair and didn't like the ideology. Well, some of us didn't either.
But there wasn't that much.
It was so blown up in the media and there were people.
Anyway, I'm here to tell you today that that narrative was inaccurate because about three, two months, not even two months after that meeting,
where Stokely was elected and the decision was made, that SNCC would be governed by an all black executive committee, which basically was anyway from the beginning any of us who weren't black and worked in SNCC,
except that the fact that that was our leaders, those were our leaders.
Stokeley and Ruby Doris sent out this letter to all SNCC staff, said, you know, as we know.
But there were personalized and the letter to me said, we understand from the SNCC photo department that you're working with Ms. Hamer on her campaign.
That's great. We want you to keep us informed. As you know, we made this decision about SNCC governance.
It's not for circulation, but we want you to have it. So basically, I never got thrown out of SNCC.
And then...
The message was keep doing what you're doing.
Yeah, but stay in touch. And then the next year, there's a SNCC staff list that's out.
There's like two Mexicans and about five white people on it. There's 75 people on it.
And, you know, so the whole thing about people being thrown out, people who wanted to work like Bob Zellner in the white community,
were told, no, we don't have the resources for that. If you want to work in the white community, we don't really want you to do it as a part of SNCC.
They just said no.
And I felt bad for Bob because he was right there from the beginning. He really put his life on the line.
And so that was a tough one for him because there were people like Bob and Casey Hayden and a number of other white southerners who had felt they had grown up in SNCC since 6061 before I came.
They really felt this sort of band of brothers. And they were. There was this whole sense of dedication to nonviolence,
dedication to, you know, integrated kind of living. Charles Sherrod was adamant about doing an integrated, you know, project in South Georgia where you could really get hurt for that.
And so there was that commitment. Some of us who came in by late 62 early 63, we weren't philosophically committed to nonviolence.
It was a strategy. You know, we, I know I brought my gun down because I was going to defend myself. So I had, you know, was not part of.
And there really weren't a huge amount of stick people that were philosophically nonviolent. Most of us were tactically nonviolent.
And yes, this is like we were brothers and sisters. But it's like, I don't know. It's something after Atlantic City, after the three civil rights workers got murdered.
There were, we had so much anger against the system that just basically couldn't see, couldn't see what was going on.
And I felt so clearly after, you know, working with, you know, the black history stuff, as I mentioned before, and seeing how that affected people's identity.
You just had to do that. Just had to do that. Basically say we, you know, we control our organization. And how important it was.
So what happened then was that there were so, some folks who were so upset with the decision they went to different foundations.
And basically my support got cut off, you know, because I continued to, I wouldn't repudiate.
I mean, that was the first question when I walk into a foundation office was, do you support Stokeley as, do you support black power? And I'd say yes, and I explain why.
You know, and it was like, I wasn't being heard. It was like, so my money was dribbling to an end.
I did work for the child development group of Mississippi doing some basic reading things because I had trained myself and the reading kind of stuff.
But that was the support, SNCC projects where those head starts were really a part of SNCC action in those communities.
And as I said, reaching into pools of adults who didn't want to mess with that voting stuff, but would be there for the kids.
So that was a part of those of us who stayed, you know, and those from the community who continued working.
I don't know how some folks did that, but they just kept on working. And they didn't have any support from the SNCC office, you know, because money was really, you know, coming to an end.
So then...
You mentioned one of the Mexican-Americans on the list.
Oh, Elizabeth "Betita" Martínez. Betita Martinez. Yeah. She ran the New York office.
People would kind of like to lump us together a lot. But we were, they had such a totally different function. She was so good at what she did.
She ran the New York office. She developed this whole network of supporters. She found not just money supporters, but she found people who could help us with that film strip maker.
She was just a genius at it. And so I worked in the field. I never worked in any office. You know, I basically worked with communities.
But yeah, just the two of us. There was a young woman down in Laurel, Mississippi that came from California, and she kind of...
And I don't remember her name, but she didn't stay after about a... about a...
I was badly run project, and she basically felt ostracized. So that was it for Latino participation, really.
So after the money dried up, basically?
Well, it's... what's happening was... I did have money enough to finish up, and I was going to finish on whatever I had started.
But Julian Bond had called me the fall of 66 and said, we're having this National Conference for New Politics.
We've invited Reies Lopez Tijerina, who was a land grant leader from New Mexico, because we're trying to make this, you know, multicultural.
And we don't know if the man speaks any English, or we just want him to feel comfortable. Would you please come, you know, and be like a hostess or whatever.
So I said, sure, because I was curious about this person, you know, and this courthouse raid business and land grant stuff, which very few Chícanos knew about land grants before Reies López Tijerina did the courthouse raid. Very few.
And so I met Reies López Tijerina and spent a couple days kind of making him at home and feel comfortable.
And this is the fall.
I was pretty poor at Spanish, you know.
When I lived and worked in northern New Mexico for 30 years, it got better.
Got a lot better, because you have to use it, or you lose it.
But Reies López Tijerina was fine in English. He didn't need any help.
Anyway, I got a letter from him about two or three months later saying, would I come work for him?
And his agenda was, I found out later, he really felt the Afro-American civil rights movement had gotten the nation's attention and the world's attention.
So effectively, he wanted to kind of co-tail onto that and get the land grant movement recognized too.
You know, and so he felt I could be a bridge between the civil rights movement and the land grant movement.
So I thought, well, I had offers to go to Crystal City, Texas to work on a radio station in the Chicano community and I offered to go over to work for César Chávez.
And I thought to myself, hey, I'm not ever moving again in my whole life, you know, because I am so tired of moving.
And B, you know, I can work on a radio station or I can work on it with a farmer-workers movement, you know, to better things in the field.
But the people that I saw could take fully beneficial use of the movement for black power, for empowerment of black people, were those farmers, because they had their own land, and they weren't going to get thrown off the plantation.
And yeah, they were a little economically free, and land owning and how important land owning is for people to be able to, you know, really empower themselves to take control of their lives.
And to me, the land grant movement represented that. It's like, there's the same thing going to happen to, you know, Latino-owned land, especially in New Mexico, where there's a lot of it.
And of course, most of it has been lost in Arizona and California. I mean, we're sitting on land grant right now, which people don't know here in Pasadena.
But if we lose that land base, and we're going to just be, and when you're landless, and you can see this now in the south, so much black land has been lost.
And after the Civil War, there was huge amount of black land ownership, and now it's down to like less than 1% of 1%.
And there's no base for people, you know. So it's, I was worried about that happening in New Mexico, in any places where there was still.
So I decided to go work for Reies López Tijerina to move to New Mexico. And no idea. They said they pay me $7 a week. Oh, I'm used to that. I've been doing that since I left college, you know.
I was $9.64 with SNCC, $750 with a vice ES, and now I'm going to make $7 in New Mexico. I'm down really mobile.
So what were some of the first things that you got involved in there?
Well, I kind of watched for a while, you know, my training. And I thought, you know, he would, because he just had a huge amount.
One thing about the land grant movement is that it's been going since 18, the Treaty of Guadalupe Hidalgo.
People kind of didn't worry about it too much until land speculators started coming in to New Mexico and stealing land away from the land grants.
And that's when people tried different ways to whether going to court or whatever to try and keep, because they were protected by the treaty.
They are the only non-Native American people in this country protected by treaty. And their land was supposedly protected.
So I thought, gee, you know, he's got this great base. I'd sit in this Albuquerque, NM office and I'd watch these sort of little old.
I mean, the average age of the land grant movement member was probably like 72. But if they come in, you know, and they'd have their, their genes, they were neat and pressed, you know, clean.
You know, not to say that, but, but worn. And battered hats, and they'd come up and they, you know, they, he was so charismatic, they kind of treated him like a god.
And then I watched and they'd slip like a couple hundred dollar bills into his hands.
So wherever, and they'd be, because they had, they sold their cattle, it would happen a lot in the fall, because that's when the cattle gets sailed and the, the sold in the sheep.
So you'd see people just coming down and, you know, giving him the money. He had this great loyal following, but he never went hardly ever went north.
He hardly ever, I mean, they all came to him. And I'm like, hmm, how does this movement work anyway? Who's organizing this? And so I suggested, let's do a newsletter. That way we can know. No, no, we didn't want to do that.
Well, I didn't know what he wanted me to do. So what happened? Because I joined him.
The end of 97, maybe early 98 somewhere in that bridge between 97, a 67, sorry, 68. Well, then the organizers for the poor people's campaign came through.
So he kind of shoved, said, you know, you, you'd take care of that. And so I did whatever I don't remember what I did, but I did.
Because there was lots of logistics. We sent a bunch of people. And so then I ended up going and living. We, there wasn't room for us in resurrection city.
And Reies López Tijerina (Rodolfo) Gonzales and Reies López Tijerina, because that we didn't have it. I don't know. Who came from California? Some of the Brown Berets came from California. You know, a bunch of them.
Did Carlos go? He was there. He was there. And Alicia Escalante remember.
But the, basically, the men didn't want the women down in resurrection city, in 10 city, because it was swamp. They just didn't want it.
So we, somebody had scored us a whole school. And we could, and they got us bunk beds. So, you know, we had, and then we had communal meals together.
So that was quite an interesting experience for me. I don't know how the SCLC folks did it, because, you know, Martin had just been assassinated.
And they're trying to organize this is something that Martin wanted to do. I think he was really on the right track in terms of how you begin.
I mean, it's something that Malcolm X understood too. How you begin to build sort of multicultural coalitions. And both, isn't it interesting? Both of those men got cut down as they are involved in that.
I'm not a conspiracy theory, but I will say if either one or both of them had lived, you would see a different movement. You would have seen a different movement come out in the late 60s and early 70s.
But as it was, they were cut down. And you just could look at the SCLC people, and I don't know how they put one foot in front of another.
You know, they wanted to do it. They were passionate about it, but they basically run rough shot over the rest of us. They made the decisions. This is their crusade for their man, their martyr, you know. And I guess in a way we should be happy we were along on it.
Well, of course, you know, Chicano's we don't put up with that shit. So we just went into our own actions. You know, we went to state department to talk about the treaty. We went to the Department of Education to talk about racism and education went to the Department of Justice to talk about police brutality had our own marches.
And then the Puerto Ricans who were so they were really very great in deciding, okay, this is funny the way it's going. They probably planned to do this anyway. So they had a whole big fiesta one day where they had food, dance, music, and then we all went across the bridge to Arlington to Bob Robert Kennedy's grave.
And that was really interesting day to watch. We learned about, you know, the Puerto Rican issues. I think some of the young lords were there as security. And they and the Brown Berets United. I mean, there was some really great interactions that went on at a much lower level than the SCLC heads, Reies López Tijerina or Reies López Tijerina Gonzales.
You know, there was people there were people making relationships. And I remember hearing people we were at the Harvard's not the Harwood school. I can't remember the name of it.
And there was a contingent of people from West Virginia or some part of Appalachia and they came in and they needed housing. So they stayed with us. And I remember hearing the women say, they're poorer than we are. They don't have any.
So they started collecting t-shirts and stuff for the kids and took them in. You know, so there was that kind of stuff going on between people just at it. We did a lot of stuff with the Native Americans because they had not very many people in their delegation. So we beeped it up with our guys.
Excuse me. So that was an experience that I came back from that. And I was like, yeah, I don't want to work for Reies López Tijerina anymore. He's a patriarch. You know, he's a patron. And the boys for various reasons that I won't go into.
So before we leave DC, can I ask a little bit about some of the others that were there in that delegation and the role that Reies López Tijerina Gonzales on.
Rodolfo "Reies López Tijerina" Gonzales was really experienced. You know, he had active in politics in Denver and he kind of understood the way things worked. And so while Reies López Tijerina considered himself the leader of the delegation, Rodolfo "Reies López Tijerina" Gonzales was de facto, you know, I think the leader.
And it was what I don't know is how they, if they made leo zones with the different departments or try to. And then I, you might have put his daughter, Nita on this to try and get appointments.
Sometimes we got appointments. Sometimes we didn't. So we just showed up. So it was, we were there maybe a week or so. And probably every other day we were going to some different place to plead the cost.
You know, for what was happening because there. And I think this is true at the time. No sense inside the beltway about what was going on in Latino communities.
The extent of police brutality, the extent of poverty, the extent of really poor educational.
The whole land issue, all of this, we just knew people didn't, they just didn't know anything about it. So you did. But I mean, the hope was we could get some kind of press to cover it. But I think we may have once or twice, but rarely was there any, you know, the education department, however, I don't know who organized this. They did hold a hearing.
And that was pretty good. A lot of people got up and testified about conditions in their schools. So I can't tell you like a lot of individuals involved, but to say that different groups from different parts of the Southwest and the West did have agendas that they wanted to speak to to the people in Washington.
And however, a forum we could devise. Because we weren't, I don't believe we were getting help with the SCLC on doing these things.
So we just did ourselves.
And did Cookie represent a different leadership? Urban. The urban Chicano. Yeah.
Okay, so you went back and you decided. Well, I went back and at that part, I was working on what we call the Chicano Press Association. Because as I said, there were 33 papers. And we were trying to develop a new service where we could get photographs out to each other and get new stories out to each other.
And so I helped organize. I always I helped organize a kind of like Southwest White meeting on the Chicano Press Association.
And then was involved a little bit and some stuff around Albuquerque, NM was involved with two newspapers because I was using my photography was also writing articles for ¿Por Que (newspaper); La Verdad (paper); Vista Por Qué in Mexico City.
I knew the author had met Stokely Carmichael somewhere, not the author. I'm sorry, the editor. And he's totally got along really well. So when Stokely Carmichael heard I was going back to visit some relatives, he said, wrote me a note and he said, you look up Mario and you tell him Stokely Carmichael said hi. So I did.
So one thing led to another and pretty soon I was doing stories for them. In the meantime, I had met Reies López Tijerina's older brother, Anselmo Tijerina.
And Anselmo was living and working up in Tierra Amarilla. And his view was that it's just not enough for this land grant movement to rely on this leader in residents in Albuquerque, NM to make the moves around the land grants.
And the people themselves should do some work. And he had heard that I had helped with some co-ops. So he started talking to me about, you know, do you think you could help us put together.
We decided what we're going to do with the land up here is instead of just talking about it, we're going to work it because it has been worked for a number of years because the markets were so bad that it didn't, you know, people couldn't hardly afford to work it.
We're going to plant potatoes. We're going to plant potatoes and then we're going to market them. We're going to have a hog farm. We're going to do all these things. And I got really interested because I was like, gee, that's a lot about the stuff that we were doing in the South.
And I said, well, you know, thanks, but I am working on this Chicano Press Association thing and doing my own writing and stuff, news stories.
And then I get this call at three o'clock in the morning, one morning saying that because then he had come down and said to me,
we're going to do a clinic. And I said, what? He said, there's a clinic up for sale because the doctor that used to serve us was called to Vietnam when he came back from Vietnam, he didn't want to live here anymore.
He wanted to go live and work in a city. He's done with us. He said, we need a clinic because women have babies on the side of the highway. If there's like a car accident and people bleed to death, we need to have a clinic.
And I said, well, you know, how are you going to get a doctor? I said, this is, you know, this was a little beyond for me. I wasn't going to go there.
And he said, well, thanks, but we're going to do it anyway. So he was working his own networks. And then I get this call at three in the morning that somebody tried to burn the clinic.
And what happened was some of those Anglo bankers and ranchers up there in the Chama Valley said to themselves, if these folks get a clinic, that land grant movement is going to be legitimized, we can't have that.
So they hired some folks to just torch it. And it, you know, it torched the northern end of it. I mean, it structurally was okay. It was just like awful.
I thought, oh crap. This is Mississippi all over again. I guess I'm going to have to go.
Someone else would have gotten the other one. Yeah, I was like, I was like, what's wrong with me? It's like, so I went up, took pictures. And we started talking about raising money for this.
I guess there was some insurance on it. Chamo had gotten the Presbyterian Church involved. They agreed to kind of take out the mortgage and work with us on it.
That clinic today is, let's see, we started it really start saw the first patients in 69. It's operating today. It's still going because of just the people saying we're going to have our own health care up here.
You know, and it was part of that whole empowerment scenario. Again, I mean, this was all we worked with and snick black power meant to us.
People empowering themselves to create these institutions. And if they wouldn't let you in, you create your own. Alternative institutions came out of that snick experience.
And that sort of northern New Mexico involvement that I ended up in was just a direct transition to that or translation of that whole thing.
It reminds me to of the black centers. Exactly. Yes. All of the stuff that they did, which is so, so overlooked, although more and more is coming to light about that, I think, which is a good thing.
It's like really very long to go into now. That is that's 30 years of work that ended up mostly building alternative institutions.
First around health care, then around how do you have people keep their land productive because you got people coming from Texas, California, mainly buying up this so-called empty land, which was ancestral land belonging in a family, but they couldn't afford to work it because the markets were so bad.
I worked with a bunch of livestock growers and weavers to add value to the traditional, traditional sheep that were grown there for years and years until the United States Department of Agriculture said they were unimproved and terrible sheep get rid of them, which made people even poorer after they did that.
The outcome of that is that we did manage to preserve this nearly extinct breed of sheep that both the Navajo weavers and the Hispanic weavers depend on, managed to create more five businesses out of either the meat or the wool or whatever.
In a sense, it's a model for how people can work, but it also is a model that says if this country is not going to help people invest in the research and development of both products and services that could be used to revitalize
the economy, the important rural economies that have a cultural base to them.
So you can do the model, but boy, you have to just catch that brass ring of funding and when it's gone, it's gone and there you are.
Your businesses, you know, we do have two businesses that are still that came out of that that are still operating out of the five that we started.
Actually three, I'm sorry, three out of the five that and they're where they should be, they're housed with, you know, the individuals that basically the businesses would benefit.
But yeah, I learned a lot about the ability of this country to just not support people empowering themselves.
I mean, we have these rural, I mean, these urban ideas about power, you know, but very little is looked at the rural, which is the tap roots of our various cultures across this country.
They came out of rural areas. That's where families used to send their kids so their kids could get connected to their culture.
You know, they'd send their kids south to Greenwood, Mississippi, or they send their kids to, you know, Taos, New Mexico, or wherever if they had moved to California, go back and see Graham, you don't get to know your people and all your relatives back there.
So there's just a tremendous loss in terms of culture, economics, and environments because somehow we don't know how to do it.
It is said we don't know how to do it, but we really do. We just rather put money someplace else.
So I keep on a little bit more about the importance of economics in terms of power and uplift and self-determination.
Well, it's often said in New Mexico at least and I think this was true in Mississippi, too.
You know, the white people got the money, the brown people got the politics, which isn't really, you know.
So you have domain over whatever you can politically manage, but the money.
And money is rooted, especially in the west here in the southwest, and in rural areas across the black belt south, is rooted in land.
And what you do with that land, you know, and so land ownership in this country is every bit as important as it's been talked about in terms of South America and South America.
And I'm really rambling right now. You're not going to get very much out of my mind.
No, no, no, no, no. I think you're pretty much like this.
So Maria, as we move towards wrapping up a little bit, I wonder if you could just reflect a little bit about some of the more recent work you've done and maybe some of the connections that you see.
And one of the things that has just floored me in a sense, if that's a good way to put that, is how the undocumented student movement has developed.
And I don't know, like I'm not real literate in everything that's going on in this movement because there is so much going on.
They just had a big meeting of about 900 people that showed up in Houston from all over the country, students that have been doing this kind of organizing around undocumented issues.
They've done such a beautiful job in California in their organizing in terms of, and they've got a lot of allies.
So, you know, they can go to school for in-state tuition and there's just a whole lot of things that they victories that they have won.
What's astounding to me, so many of them tell me, we study SNCC, they said.
And I said, really, they said of all the civil rights movements, that's the one we feel is the closest to us.
You know, the values in SNCC, you know, how we're sort of moving, we're an anti- celebrity leader, you know, of an organization.
We feel like we all are doing this together, we're in teams together.
I'm astounded at the courage I know of some that purposely got detained.
So they could then work with the detainees and say, you know, here's a telephone number of a lawyer.
Do you know you have these kinds of rights? I mean, that takes so much courage to do that.
And there's such a force. They really, their movement is just, they went through kind of what we went through.
You know, there was this time in the early sit-ins where it was about getting a hamburger.
And then Mrs. Fannie Lou Hamer wrote this great article saying, it's bigger than a hamburger.
And they kind of went through that too. It was like, this is about us because we've been in this country, this is the only thing we know.
And we need to have this kind of relief. And then it was like, hey, wait, no, it's bigger than that. It's our families too.
And they need to be included in this. And then they, so they moved wider, which is a big, courageous move, because they did have some successes.
You know, at making it around young people who wanted an education, so that they could contribute to this country and to their families' lives.
And so they are just heroes to me. They're people that I look up to. I feel like they have taken the best of our legacy so far.
And are moving it into an area that is so important to us in this country, not just as a Latina, but this country needs really.
I mean, Latino populations have revitalized whole cities and towns across the Midwest, in so many other places.
You have people that have just, it's, anyway.
So this has made me realize that when you're in that kind of 17 to 35 group, you think everything should happen like tomorrow.
And it doesn't. It's like 50 years later. It feels like so much of our legacy was, it's been written out of history books.
You have to really spend, that's what a lot of my teaching's been about over the years. I taught SNCC as a case history for 16 years.
It just kids saying to me like, why didn't I learn this in school? I said precisely.
You know, and it's a, they're carrying our legacy on. And I hope that they can hang in there, you know.
And I'm not going to counsel them to be patient because they're at their best sometimes when they are impatient.
But they also, I remember they, there was a period of time where the leaders were saying, we're going to stop some stuff right now.
We're going to stop all the Facebook, all the Twitter. We're going to stop everything. We've got to reflect.
And I remember Miss Baker telling us after 64 and that horrible, you know, convention and what happened with that.
That we should take time and reflect and we didn't. And we paid for that.
And they went through this kind of thing where they worked so successfully in Congress to get the, the DACA, and I'm not explaining it very well.
But it's, it's relief, it's relief for a far undocumented kids that were, they were born here and, or came here at the age of two or three.
And would be, they would not be on, couldn't get deported. If they did certain things served in the military, finished their high, their college.
There was a certain kinds of things and then they could be on a road to citizenship. And they just about got it through and it, you know, it didn't get all the way through.
And they went through that same setback that we did in 1964 when we were trying to get the Mississippi Freedom Democratic Party.
You know, but I think they've done a better job at, we're going to regroup now. We're not giving up. We're going to be as strong as we've ever been.
They're so supportive of each other. So I guess I want to kind of like end by saying that even if it takes 50 years for the best aspects of a movement, you know, to be able to go into a generation.
It might not be the next generation or even the generation after that. But it will be there if it is as solid as I think, you know, our kind of approach to building empowerment strategies was.
That's all I'm going to talk about. There she wrote.
So we're wrapping up here. I just want to acknowledge that we have Maria's wonderful daughter, Sabina Zunigab, Varela. Also here with us.
She did hear her on the tape a bit. And finally, I just want to say thank you. Thank you for your work and for sharing with us today. We appreciate it.
Thank you for doing this.
This has been a presentation of the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.